[Musique]
je le tiens alors c'est vous le petit
bonhomme qui arrête pas de me suivre
partout le petit bonhomme comment
osez-vous je vous signale que je suis
d'une taille parfaitement respectable
pour un numpa lumpa unpalum quoi sachez
qu'à lumpaland je suis un personnage de
haute stature on me surnomme le colosse
désolé mesdames et messieurs bonjour à
tous je m'appelle Willy je suis une
sorte de magicien préparezvous à être
bluffé par
uneèreinventeur je vous présente le
promou
fantastiqueig
pas de
chocolatier il fait les meilleur
chocolat du
[Musique]
monde il est doué doué tout le monde
peut'en offrir
Mme les pvres il ne supporte pas le mot
pauvre vous allez lu
pass
ch vousurez plus qu' surun B surte
m'rive vous laissez pas faire par
BRZ V la figure j'ai une idée on fait
quoi alors du chocolat bien
s
[Musique]
toutes les bonnes choses dans ce monde
ont commencé par un
rêve alors ne renonce pas
au je crois que c'est l'heure de changer
le
[Musique]
monde
bonne nuit je passe à
[Musique]
l'horizont qu' a-t-il il y a quelque
chose puisque vous avez dit c'est rien
très
bien
[Musique]
vous recommencez dites-moi ce qu'il y a
sinon je vous assure que vous allez tâer
de mon
[Musique]
curd